[Music]
hello and thank you for
attending this
lab roots event
the title of my presentation is sample
workflow optimization
with focus on sample preparation and
prevention of contamination
all of the
topics are pretty pertinent to cannabis
and hemp operations
the biggest issue
usually is it within a sample intake
sample preparation
and overall
looking at heavy metals
and microbials for potential
contamination sources
that line of today's talk is to go
through
uh sample workflow and how do you best
optimize that and knowing that
when the sample comes in the door you
want to have a controlled workflow and
process
part of that is with paperwork and that
paperwork is typically with a chain of
custody
and a track and trace system
seed to sale
such as metric
biotrack mj freeway there's a number of
different offerings there
a lot of times the regulatory
jurisdiction or the state will determine
that truck and trade system
but overall that that has to be included
in the overall chain of custody and
management of of the paperwork along
with the sample and
in addition limbs
limbs is a kind of the the glue that
holds all
the
sample preparations the sample
information
uh the order number
the bar coding the labeling it it's it's
kind of the brains of the operation
in terms of how the sample moves through
the lab to the final result in c of a
generation
another aspect
that's often overlooked is how how to
ensure sample sterility or overall how
do you manage splitting up a sample so
that the microbial testing is is begun
first and also in a sterile field that's
usually done with a laminar flow hood a
bsc cabinet or something similar
so that that sterility can be maintained
uh throughout the microbial testing as
well as that with heavy metals heavy
metals
usually is very prone to contamination
and therefore doing that sample
splitting step is is really important
and sample preparation
there's a variety of different ways to
prepare samples for
[Music]
extraction and final analysis
a lot of that is
based on your throughput what your goals
are as a laboratory but mainly ball
mills
they're very popular you can end up
up to 16 samples in one run so that
could help with throughput
so there are some benefits there there's
blade grinders and
i'll touch a little bit on cryogenics
and then any special considerations
and what i've seen
in some testing labs is the
prone
to having contamination contamination
can be
can stop your testing altogether until
you figure out and investigate what is
causing that contamination and so i'll
i'll put some ideas out there
on that topic
i'm not going to go much into sampling
sampling is is very critical it starts
the entire process in how the sample is
is representative of a batch or or what
you're picking up from from a harvest
for example
there are many guidelines on the
internet for this
usda put out a guidance document in 2021
colorado has a very mature program
they've published sops on sampling how
best to accomplish that they've also
within the last year they i've included
a video link for sampling
very uh a good information
it's about 50 minutes long it has a lot
of useful
techniques
as well you want to make sure that you
have a good statistical sampling plan or
sop and that's usually dictated by their
regulatory jurisdiction that you're
operating in
as well as you know making sure that
that is truly a representative sample of
of a batch as well as it's it's randomly
sampled
once that sample um
is uh
you know
basically selected for sampling
a lot of times the the cultivator grower
will provide a dry sample however
it's up to the laboratory to determine
is it truly dry and if it's not
you will measure the moisture but then
also have to accommodate that drying
with either a vacuum oven
that's
usually a little bit of a gentler
technique in terms of drying a sample
is very critical
to ensure that the material is dry so
that when you homogenize you don't get
clumping of that plant material and then
not truly get a representative sample
now the moisture content
has been published aoac
has a very good document for
determining moisture for plant material
and it's available publicly on the
internet
limbs lenses is kind of out of topic for
this
talk however
limbs does provide a way to
guide the sample through in a digital
manner versus a paper manner and
maintaining that information
along the way
through the analysis so the sample
details are usually entered as soon as
that happens there's an order number
that's generated that is assigned a
unique identifier for that sample and
that is carried through the entire
analysis in the lab
other information that linds can house
besides just
you know bar coding and labeling and
identifiers or
matrix type so if there's a variety of
different strains that can be populated
in limbs as well as sample mass
and the analysis that the user has
requested
and other
unique information perhaps there's a a
rush on that a particular test all of
that can be
collected and maintained in the limb
system
now this is just kind of a basic
overview of what happens during intake
the client will first place an order and
that's usually done through a web portal
and that can also be maintained through
the limb system that will then trigger a
sample pickup that pickup is usually
internal at the laboratory they send out
a sampling technician that sampling
technician then picks up the sample
and
ensures that it is sampled following the
internal procedure
that information is then documented and
on a chain of custody that chain of
custody has
the client information
what samples were picked up
what testing has been ordered
and the the time frame or the turnaround
that the customer is expecting so basic
information as well as the laboratory
information where the location is the
the name of the lab and any sort of
licensing information
that then transfers to the lab it's kind
of a redundant step but that chain of
custody and the manifest that is
associated with shipping or transferring
that sample from a cultivator
to the laboratory via metric is called
metric manifest that's usually attached
to the coc
then that ends up going into the metric
and as well as into the lymph system
that lab technician is basically taking
control of that sample at the laboratory
the sample then is
begun
as part of the intake the masses are
entered based on the weights and then
that unique identifier or barcode is
then attached to that sample
the lab text will then receive the
sample
and then batch it for analysis that
sample then is homogenized variety of
different techniques
extracted and then prepared for analysis
that analysis also involves crm
materials for your calibrators pcs and
final
sample
preparation whether it's in a vial
or however um centrifuge tubes for
example that's when it's actually
prepared
now sample collection
uh goes back a little bit into the
sampling however how are you how is that
best accomplished and testing
laboratories usually will have that
attached and
in their sops and internal procedures
however there are some common uh
sampling containers or you can use
whirlpack bags for example or or some
forest form a sterile bag and then
you're you're wanting to make sure that
it's not been tampered with so that when
it arrives at the laboratory
for visual inspection there hasn't been
any sort of
um
contamination or potential foreign
material that's entered that sample
and then again the the metric uh is
critical for um
tracing that package and transferring it
to the laboratory and that's also
assigned a metric tag and that gets
associated with that sample as well
and this is just a another example of a
just a chain of custody the chain of
custody
is then
electronically transferred into limbs
all of that information has to be
reviewed by the technician
upon entry into the system
now sample labeling there's a lot of
different ways to do labeling you can
purchase
zebra printers
there's
bar coding and sample tracking
information that gets attached to that
label barcoding could be either a qr
code
or a linear code like a 128 code
that can actually transfer to all the
containers that are used to process that
sample
so part of the sample intake once it's
been labeled
and processed is basically to ensure
that there is a sterile field upon
splitting of that sample to go to the
various tests this is often an
overlooked procedure
some regulatory jurisdictions actually
require this to happen so
it is a good practice
knowing that microbials are so prone to
contamination that you're doing it in a
sterile environment when you actually
prepare the sample
after the weights are made
then the sample preparation can begin
and usually microbials is the first
step in this process because it's a long
process
it can be multi-date particularly if
it's
a plating technique which can be
incubated up to three days
and again part of that sample
splitting there is a retain or reserve
sample so if there's a
any sort of retest or question in those
results those retains have to be stored
somewhere so not thinking about storage
can end up being kind of disastrous
because then the samples can accumulate
and get all kind of uh integrated into
the workflow so having a you know either
a walk-in refrigeration depending on
your volume
this was just like a probably the a very
large um
storage system you can buy from uline
for if you have the ability to store it
at room temperature some states require
refrigeration
and just making sure you have that
capacity
in mind because it those retain periods
can be very long some are 45 days
for example here in colorado it's 90
days for pesticide samples
it's seven days in other jurisdictions
such as ohio so
having that in mind knowing that you can
turn over and waste that sample quickly
is really important but you have to
also know that there is
a retain potential at your at your
laboratory
and
segwaying into
the actual sample preparation
how how best to uh choose the technology
that will work
uh best and there's a variety of
different technologies whether you use
a bling a blade grinder a blender
a ball mill a coffee grinder it all
depends on what your throughput is and
how large your sample sizes are
if you have a large sample size say up
to 100 grams then you need a system that
is fairly flexible and can handle that
that mass of
of material however if you know that you
can do one to two grams of sample then
perhaps a ball mill is a more
appropriate choice the nice thing about
the ball mills whether it's the omni or
specs geno grinder is that they can
process samples
in centrifuge tubes usually a 50 ml
size you add in two stainless steel
balls
and that proceeds to
basically
add to the ball mill and
process that sample
that sample then becomes pulverized and
then it assures that you have a
relatively small particle size however
some labs prefer coffee grinders coffee
grinders are relatively inexpensive
but you have to consider the cleaning if
you process in a centrifuge tube it can
process fairly rapidly and it stays in
that same tube throughout the process
that's
definitely helps to keep the
contamination issue at bay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
shown in the last example is just a dry
milling process however cryogenic
grinding has its place
if
there is a volatilization issue
for example terpenes and pesticides
are prone to be volatile and or degrade
at higher temperatures
so hydrogenics has been around for other
food commodities
there's a variety of different
techniques you can pour the liquid
nitrogen directly into a container and
i'll show a video example of that
uh you can also pre-freeze in a minus 80
freezer the material to
achieve
embrittlement of the material
in addition
you can
basically immerse it into a mortar and
pestle and then and basically pulverize
the material
there are some benefits to doing it in a
more controlled manner manner where you
have a continuous flow of liquid
nitrogen into what they call a freezer
mill
that ensures that the entire
sample is immersed in a in a specialized
sample container
and there's also
an ability to add directly to certain
grinding apparatus such as
a basic
container that can
accommodate up to four liters depending
on if you buy a commercial
type grinder or
restaurant quality
grinder such as a
robo coupe
and this is a an example of how it's
submersed this is a p11 first grinder
this holds up to 1.6 liters so you can
do up to 100 grams of
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
so sample preparation
kind of switches gears when you look at
microbials there isn't that
homogenization step where it's grind
ground into a finer particle
that ends up causing more problems with
release of
for example aspergillus
so another technique where you place the
material into a whirlpool bag with a
filter
and you put the the actual plant
material on one side and then the wind
on the other and you gently kind of
macerate or
at first i was like stomacher what's
that and so it actually does work and it
simulates your stomach and that's why
it's called stomacher and that actually
basically macerates that material so
that
it gently releases
what potential contaminants could be in
that that plant material
another aspect and this is more
for
plating is basic control of of
contamination
although this this looks like a kind of
a cluttered hood uh it it basically has
all the supplies needed and dedicated to
the process
so making sure that you have your your
appropriate ppe while you're working
within a vsc
or a laminar cabinet
either one and then swabbing down that
work area ensuring that it's a sterile
field
other items sterile pipette tips are
usually dedicated for this process any
sort of reagents
diluent for example
can be purchased
already sterile
sterilized water
and then if you
say undo a cap make sure that it's going
in and out of that hood
capped and want to minimize opening and
closing as much as possible
and as well as having that environment
be clutter free usually
having a dedicated set of pipettes is
recommended
so that
those can be sterilized and cleaned at
the same time as part of the process and
then making sure that the the vents or
the
actual fans that are present
uh throughout the the hood are left open
so that you're actually protected while
you're working
in the hood
and this is just a
you know if
you are potentially looking at pcr
uh pcr does require some some room
separation at a minimum any microbial uh
analyses does require a separate room
however pcr if there is the budget and
um
you know there there's
at least some thought about how to set
up that workflow to keep the processes
as separated as possible for example
you'll still have that sample processing
where you might be prepping what they
call a master mix
and then the next step you'll be doing a
purification or
extraction step and in this instance you
want more of a positive pressure from
the room
and then the next room and they're all
kind of interconnected with the workflow
going towards the top is pcr setup and
amplification that's where you would
want negative pressure so that if it was
amplified or those
amplificons get aerosol that's not going
throughout
that workspace so
it it may not be possible to have three
separate rooms however
if it is
well enough away from each other
that of benefit so that you don't
amplify or cross contaminate as you
perform the other steps
and another area of
concern in
isolating or having a separate room is
heavy metals heavy metals
is prone to contamination it's a very
sensitive technique and if you know
anything about the world around us is
surrounded by by metals or metals in the
air in general so controlling that
environment is very critical
uh and making sure that it remains
fairly contaminant free and
recently with the quality of drywall
that has mercury so
knowing the sources of your building
materials if you're doing some
construction for example if you have any
sort of drop ceiling there could be
particulates from that
trying to minimize the amount of
particulates and
potentially generating particulates on
surfaces
will allow
a little bit cleaner environment
uh
you know if the clean room standard is
not necessary as long as it's controlled
and that there is dedicated ventilation
in that space
another concern is the use of glassware
quartz is usually preferred over
borosilicate
as well as metallic utensils
probably want to at least
test the ability for
the use of metallic items best to
probably just avoid them all together
if you do use them you would have to do
a verification that there are no metals
leaching from that material
as well as
use of trace metal reagents they're very
expensive
and there's other options for double
distillation and doing your own process
to kind of reuse those materials
due to the expense and then having a
dedicated set of pipettes
weighing apparatus for the metals
room or operation
in addition
you can purchase
metal specific or contaminant free
centrifuge tubes if if needed as well as
if you are grinding and you want to
verify that that blade grinder isn't
imparting any sort of
metal contaminant
to the material a ceramic homogenizer is
preferred so perhaps you at this point
you would use more of a vortex or a ball
mill shaking apparatus to extract the
material
a microwave digester is usually required
for
digesting the various types of cannabis
matrices
and part part of the
cleanup is to verify that during a use
between batches that that
teflon
bomb or
sample holder is actually clean how did
how is that verified well there's
usually a cleaning process and that
and you can cycle through the digestion
say for 15 minutes at 200 degrees
and then adding that
basically rinse it or a wash to ensure
that that carryover doesn't
isn't carried over to the next sample so
having a cleaning verification step or
ensuring that that apparatus is
maintained clean and goes through a very
rigorous
cleaning process is very important just
skipping that step alone
could ensure that there is contaminants
carried through the next sample analyses
or batch
and there are some other concerns for
heavy metals
there's the room isolation making sure
that that is in place
epoxy or resin benches over stainless
steel
having that dedicated filtered air and
exhaust for that room is another way to
eliminate contaminants
sometimes even in the filtration heavy
metals or dust particulates can
accumulate in the filtration system so
having a good maintenance plan in place
uh dedicated ppe for that particular
operation so not wearing the same lab
coat that you wore in sample prep going
into a heavy metals room having
disposable
lab coats and booties and a sticky tack
mat
as you enter that room it will eliminate
that dust particulate or particulate
generation
and then another step that is often
overlooked is preconditioning those
consumables like anything that you
use for preparation of the sample
pipettes
pipette tips centrifuge tubes
the all that plastic wear needs to be
soaked in a in an acid bath prior to
being in service or use and glassware
probably best just to eliminate it all
together
it can be a source of contamination
but however quartz has been shown to be
a little bit
less of a concern in terms of trace
elements
there are a variety of different
materials
the high density and low density
polyethylene polypropylene ptfe all of
them have their pros and cons a ptfe or
teflon is very popular it's very
chemically resistant and has the lowest
amount of trace elements but all of that
also has to be verified either through a
c of a
or tested internally to ensure that
there isn't leaching of heavy metals
from that material
and
use of high grade water
for all your cleaning and sample
preparation and trace metal grade
reagents
trying to use acs grade is probably not
going to to be
a good option although it's cheaper
it does carry
more heavy metal contaminants
so in summary sample intake
takes into account many of the
testing process
so from sample
sampling at a facility bringing the
sample into the facility and then
starting the the actual analysis and how
that is done
and split between those different tests
maintaining a sterile field is critical
so that
is definitely something to consider as
well limbs limbs actually ties all that
sample information together
so between the the sample being
entered into a web portal for ordering
that test all the sample information
that the
client has provided gets entered as well
as the chain of custody information
metric everything gets tied together by
uh having a lens system
sample preparation it will
be dependent on your actual operation so
whether you have 100 samples a day or
100 samples a week
will probably define what
technology works best
ball mills blade grinders they all
accomplish the same thing reduction in
particle size
however how best to
make them work for your operation will
be highly dependent on your sample
throughput and the size of your samples
how to address contamination up front is
usually in the building design if that
building design does not accommodate two
separate rooms or operations for your
microbials and heavy metals
it can be
problematic and cause
uh
issues in terms of
contamination and or workflow
down the road so having that kind of up
front
might eliminate some of those issues
and then heavy metals and microbials are
mentioned here obviously potency and
pesticides and terpenes can be prone to
contamination through other workflow
processes
however
having these particular
very sensitive and environmental
concerns
addressed through either
building design
up front and then steps you can take to
minimize the contamination as you're
working through the analyses
heavy metals
picking picking consumables reagents
and
other
working tools that are plastic wear will
be helpful and having cleaning
procedures in place
as well for microbials making sure that
there's a process for
maintaining
sterility working within a bsc or
laminar hood
for your operation will overall help to
contain
and make sure that contaminants are not
introduced into your your sample
analysis
and with that i want to thank lab roots
for inviting me
to speak today as well as thank you for
your time and attention if you have any
further questions please feel free to
contact me
you